okay Rebecca Harris time slightly
terrifying let's go for those who don't
know also let me give a shout out
let me accept the challenge but let me
give a shout-out to GM and their Oh dick
ski
oh dear cold uh story in the chat also
shout out
Goldust Tori accepts wait s oh haha this
is so G folks
Goldust Tori Goldust Tori you better be
rooting for the underdog which is me
because I need all the support I can get
okay good luck Daniel let's focus play
this many times before against him
Queenie 5a Bishop d3 it's not getting
needed oh this is scary but reasonable
maybe Brooke D G 1 and G 4 oh dear just
lost everything
let's not get mean it it's a one goal
let's take on g7 first mmm this is bad
this is really bad
what happened to my position am I not
surviving this and this move it's gonna
take here
how much material do I have for gage 3i
here wait I may be coming back kind of I
gotta stay focused
let's take the rook
have a smooth
ah no stop it
where does my night go okay I'll post No
yes Rosen trap against narrowed its key
oh I feel so good that's going into the
compliation Meredydd Sookie not familiar
with the resin trap near this key has a
video series on like dirty bullet tricks
but he hasn't covered that one yet okay
let's play another game thank you for
the bits contact Buffalo I'm not getting
adopted at least within the next nine
games
morgy down the pong oh let's not lose a
queen thank you
something leopard wanna win the pawn
yeah this is a little bit annoying
actually this is very annoying let's
come around the other way and that's
what tight just have to hold on tight I
just have no moves mmm this is so
unfortunate I guess I could defend take
my pawn this meets or catch aids take my
pond da ha it's not falling for my traps
anymore okay let's walk the King this
way and win the b-pawn and then try and
promote the a pawn da ha stopping all my
plans it's really annoying Oh No
okay I lost my rook no more rosin chap
one more trick okay
he could have doubled on passante okay
how's it rough it was really rough it's
play E for what does he play in z4c five
okay let's play a Grand Prix attack
I like this position might be losing a
pawn but I'll get some initiative take
with Knights
Oh today maybe this move and then the
son of I'm that move I don't walk around
I won't play be for us so let's play
rook b-1b for ya take that way and
double up the rooks hopefully rook could
be 7 mm I could take a knight but that's
dubious oh let's play rugby 7 and then
take the knight and then this move and
the knight c3 my knight will be annoying
from d5
oh let's yeah I go that way hmm Queen h3
to e3 both bones attacked I here not
sure if I'm making progress each for
looped move back not sure how to attack
him turning this oh I'm getting needed
what's getting needed oh that's so
unfortunate like my position to play the
walrus don't mess with the Loras ah he
stopped my ball respond let's try and
meet him Bishop d6 I guess this looks
fun actually takes here what is this
let's take your first mmm Queen e7
castle I'll play this move he takes my
bishop I made an e3 to play a 4
a-five training stuff this is so unusual
let's save the Bishop takes rook take
this thing takes takes there there this
mate it's so close to mate where's my
mates I'm searching
not seeing it hmm I'm so sad so close to
working I was so close yet so far
I'll just take pawns and hope for the
best
pin probably pin and lose take another
poll
there's my time what happened to my time
okay let's not lose more games okay this
is fun opening this move let's play
Bishop III maybe Queen b3 I should be 5
that's annoying let's play this move
when a 4th there's some pin I want to
win the pawn I can take in Queen a4 ok
we're gonna trade and take the swear
hmm
um I just feel slow Oh the Brooks
hanging on a hate that's nice let's move
back I'm up up full piece play Bishop
here also up on time somehow this move
don't trap my queen g5 I can take it
okay take this thing do this 94 I
respect him for playing on because I've
given away lots of winning positions in
the past
hmm
slightly annoying ah am i doing
oh no let's take this thing no aha
Oh my position was so good - oh I just
gave it all the way okay that's so sad
you so Oh what to do
let's just recover let's play let's play
this move 97 to g6 just have to stay
focused defend I'll reconnect the rooks
I have to take this unfortunately not
the worst thing ever I have six king of
seven Oh No
this is the worst thing ever but how bad
is it it's pretty bad have to play c6 I
hope is that white can't break through
not so sure about this so okay Harrison
I'm about to get adopted a module
modulus schemer thanks for the rain this
is really painful
yeah let's um let's play another one of
these openings hey listen
takes a four to play this the smooth
what to do Queen this is not pretty
again I am trying but what am I trying
to do there there my time is running out
okay to give up a rook free pawn free
pawn defend things maybe let's take this
thing
what's the conclusion here only down a
bishop take that da ha can have this
move
oh yes I move as rough it's six and a
half to half okay play this line now we
played this before I'm losing a pawn
already okay I'm trying to fight play
that check just to spite check will
trade off all the rooks oops almost too
bad not slip let's put the bishop here
let's put do that move I should play a
five open the position maybe Bishop here
wow this moves nice take him take okay
this is my game to win keep pushing the
pawn play this move
aha let's play this move house nice move
it's getting unclear again play like
this move go for activity just want to
push up on no I want to clean up lon no
are you serious I was winning the whole
game no I just blundered I ran out of
chucks - that was actually kind of
tricky oh that's so sad even like the
games I'm winning I'm not winning it's
not good
okay let's try not to tilt I think the
trick is I have to get him tilted which
was I mean it was an attempt he's after
the first game this is another kind of
playable position by King H 2 and G 3
it's gonna be annoying let's do this and
try and get an e5 or f5 play this move
takes and I guess I mean g4 I guess it
should be one so sad I'll cure oh this
is really sad play this move the ship's
about to be trapped what was B 3 this
move now okay another reasonable
position let's take a queen do this
develop I wanna bring the King to d3 or
to c6
[Music]
no I'm too slow it's so sad they didn't
have to one-and-a-half or no in half to
half
oh no on two games away from getting
adopted no I don't think so
do you not think so to go this way I
learned from my previous mistakes a lot
of previous mistakes to learn from
mistake number one I spend too much time
just ink number two I drop pawns
everywhere okay but if you like this is
reasonable as usual let's bring the key
into the center defend the pawns hmm
Chuck let's play Chuck I'll bring that
came back I want to take the knight and
then we have five do this move and this
move I guess whoa what is this
positions falling apart oh this was
really bad I can I don't know what my
hope is oh that's not good that's really
bad
I'm one game away from getting adopted
oh dear heaven playing us very bad
opening but okay I have a bishop on c3
getting trapped already really Bishop's
getting trapped already check how bad is
this this is pretty bad
you have to go for crazy stuff check mmm
I do this I'm already down a piece but
I'm sacking another piece because why
not
oh it's another king hunt I don't see
mate like Queen f7 where's my mates g4
no I have to defend my team first lift
the rook there we go now f4 jack
is this Jack Jack Jack meets let's go no
adoption for you no adoption for you
what was that game I was a weird game I
was a really strange oh well the game
okay that will be part one of not
getting adopted against neared its key
except in the title I don't want to
spoil it so it'll be trying not to get
adopted or running from adoption
I should have the chat open
I'd be down to play another I'm also
down to end it there and can stop the
suffering